all right what's going on guys this is
rob welcome back to geek culture
explained and welcome back to another
episode of
hype train where we talk about the
ending of episodes and
wrap everything up with a theory now
here's a funny thing about the ending
of falcon in the winter soldier episode
number three right here's the ending
here's the thing about this ending
there's not much there i will say
like there's the party that's a fan
wants to believe that we're gonna get do
more like a part of you just wants to
believe that right because like people
in wakanda
latvia which just sounds like latviria
doctor doom invades wakanda steals a
vibranium done like i really really want
that
i don't think we're gonna get it i think
it'd be awesome to see do more but i
don't think we're gonna get it what made
do-more so cool for those of you guys
who never read it what made doumor so
cool was that doctor doom
basically had to go to the panther god
blast and then made an argument of like
he's going to steal all of vibranium
he's going to amplify his magical power
and then he's going to rule the world as
a dictator but it would actually be a
better place and the panther god's like
i get where you're coming from and then
allowed him to take all the vibranium
and like doom basically became god it
took like the entirety of the superhero
community to bring him down
and the only way to stop him was that
t'challa had to basically render all the
vibranium across the world inert like
like basically remove the one thing that
made vibranium valuable so they were
just giant
hunks of rock they were worthless and
initially was believed that like wakanda
was going to lose all of its money but
like they had actually bought up a bunch
of debt from different countries around
the world so like first world countries
owed wakanda money
[Laughter]
so they were basically guaranteed
paychecks like for forever right the
nation was always going to have money
coming in and so it was it was cool it
was it was a really really really cool
story i can almost guarantee we're not
going to get that anytime soon but the
fan
in me that wants to create outlandish
theories wants it to be true
however while there isn't a whole lot to
go on with regards to the ending of this
particular
this particular episode in terms of what
we saw during the episode itself
man there's a lot and here's the thing
right the big question on everybody's
mind
is who's power broker right like who is
the power broker who's the one running
the show who's the one that's like
developing all these powers
i think power broker is a throwaway guy
i don't think power broker is important
i think that like there's there's
something much much bigger going on here
right so a few things that i want to
point out one
i don't believe the flag smashers are
important i think that the girl is and i
think she's gonna be important later on
and there'll be a reason for that i
think baron zemo is going to be
important but i don't think they're
going to be the big reveal at the end of
the show and i don't think it's going to
be power broker i think it's the person
power broker is working for
i think it's general thunderbolt ross i
think he's the one that's running
everything all right here's the thing
here's the thing right here's the thing
crazy
crazy time hype train all right here's
the thing about this right
come on y'all troop let's go for a ride
on the hype train y'all okay here's the
thing here's the thing that i think is
going on here
what do we know about general
thunderbolt ross right well there's huge
differences between thunderbolt ross and
like baron zemo right we know that baron
zemo his family was killed in sokovia
baron zemo just wants to get rid of
superheroes
done right just like superheroes gotta
go but general thunderbolt ross is more
pragmatic where he knows that
superheroes have their place if he
didn't believe superheroes had their
place the sokovia accords wouldn't
regulate superheroes they would outlaw
them
right so like we know that like he's
like okay the world needs superheroes
but there's got to be some kind of rules
and regulations that they have to follow
in order to be able to do their job so
there's huge differences between the two
of these guys right so i think what the
big reveal is going to be here
is that the power broker was contacted
and was basically
hired by thunderbolt ross on behalf of
the federal government and why do that
well because what we know about magipor
right if you've never read marvel comics
madrid poor is like the most eisley of
the marvel universe right you guys
remember in star wars when like obi-wan
kenobi was hanging out with luke
skywalker and he was like most eisley
you will never find a more wretched hive
of scum and villainy that's madrapore
man
even in the comics shield the whole nine
yards they're like yeah man we're not
gonna go there unless we have to it's
the south side of chicago and the marvel
universe right like you never go there
alone like it's it's
it's it's a pretty rough spot to be in
right because there aren't really any
rules there you know like if you're a
shield agent and you go into magipore
then you get whatever you get right i
mean if you're foolish enough to go on
there on your own and you die less on
your shoulders right
governments around the world give
madrapor a wide berth
in terms of what they can do and so
because of that like there's no better
place to go to than that right like if
you are thunderbolt ross and you are
basically trying to find a way to
essentially
recreate the super soldier serum which i
think is what he's trying to do then
hire somebody in madge report it's never
going to trace back to you right you
just go through
shell company shell company shell
company or aliases or whatever you go
through a guy through a guy through a
guy through a guy who goes to the power
broker and says i've got a deal for you
right now the question is like why bring
in somebody like wilford nagel right all
right here's the thing wilfred nagel was
a character who appeared in truth red
white and black it was basically the
story of isaiah bradley and marvel
comics and the idea was that after steve
rogers became captain america while he
was fighting in europe the government
wanted to create more and so what they
did is they snatched up 300 black
americans they took him to a fake
military camp in mississippi called camp
cathcart and then just started
experimenting on them and just injecting
them with different forms of the super
soldier serum sometimes it was wholly
different variations sometimes it was
just
huge amounts of the serum like all but
seven of these guys died and then over
the course of the story the only one who
survived the whole experience was isaiah
bradley we know isaiah bradley exists in
the marvel cinematic universe we know
that he's part of the experiment that
led to those variations of captain
america that exists out there now i'm
not saying thunderbolt ross was the one
who experimented on isaiah bradley but
it wouldn't be that hard for thunderbolt
ross to pick up the research that was
done
and then hand it over to somebody else
and say make a better version of this
right we know that because wilford nagle
in the comics was the one who was
experimenting on all those guys in camp
cathcart right so that's how you get
wilfred nagel from the comics in the mcu
he was the guy he was basically the guy
who was originally there when abraham
erskine created the super soldier serum
and he was the best person to hire to
try to recreate it thunderbolt ross is
trying
to recreate the super soldier serum in
order to create more super soldiers why
one because i think that's gonna go into
the launch of weapons plus but two
i think he's basically creating his own
mighty avengers team but he's gonna call
him the thunderbolts why okay in marvel
comics you got the civil war event
right superhero regulation everything
pops off captain america versus iron man
for the heavyweight championship of the
world and the right to be a superhero
and so because of that
what you had is you basically had like
tony stark and you had reed richards and
you had hank pym
uh hang pam ant-man bad guys won and so
you got the mighty avengers which were
basically a secondary avengers team that
served the purpose of rounding up people
who hadn't registered and then taking
him to a prison until they did choose to
register i think that's what he's gonna
do right i think that thunderbolt ross
at the end of all this one he's creating
the super soldier serum too
i don't know whether or not it'll be
successful i wouldn't be surprised if it
just gets destroyed in some form or
fashion
and then three i think that if it does
survive he's gonna take a final dose of
it crazy idea here he might become the
red hulk i don't think that's gonna
happen but it'd be cool if it did
but he's basically going to snatch up
baron zemo right baron zemo's probably
gonna end up back in jail and it's gonna
be one of those post-credits scenes like
you saw when iron man was creating the
avengers and he was going around and
visiting different people i think you're
gonna have that right but like he's
gonna go visit like thunderbolt ross is
gonna go see baron zemo and say hey
like you know we're kind of on the same
page here you're a little more extreme
than me
but like you're gonna come work for me
right and basically and script you know
conscripts him into the thunderbolts i
think the girl who's a leader of the
flag smashers is gonna become a
thunderbolt i think that abomination is
to come back because we know he's still
alive the leader
we know he's still alive right those
guys from the original incredible hulk
movie with edward norton they're still
there right they still exist
i think they're all going to be brought
in to the thunderbolts and the whole
purpose behind this team is going to
serve the
sort of the basis of we can't rely on
conventional male to
military tactics to confront superheroes
but given everything that's happened
sokovia civil war the events of infinity
war
half the life in the universe being
blanked out of existence the great big
huge battle that we saw in
at the at the end of avengers in game we
cannot allow superheroes to just
continue to run
unchecked but the sokovia accords as
they're made don't work so i'm going to
run a black ops team well they're
literally going to be a covert black ops
wet work team that the government has
the ability to just disavow so think
like the superhero version of mission
impossible and like when things pop off
like they sit in the thunderbolts and
the thunderbolts just round people up
that's what it's going to be right
that's that's how it's going to function
but i think the big reveal behind all
this i think power broker is going to be
a throwaway guy and i think the big
reveal behind all of this is thunderbolt
ross is the one that initiated
all of this stuff right he's basically
the big guy behind the scenes pulling
the strings i think it's going to be him
but any event let me know what you guys
think down in the comments section this
is a great episode of hype train
and i will catch you all later peace